what's the most amount of time you've
put into a screenplay
and was it worth it the most amount of
time i put into a screenplay
it's tough because i haven't measured
exactly how much
time i've worked on it but i know that
the longest from
idea to a finished draft
was five years
and that's just to the end of the
screenplay that screenplay is still
sitting there not you know no film has
been made out so that's just
five years to what is for me a finished
draft
um sort of working on it sporadically
sometimes
every day other times it kind of sat
dormant for a few months and i worked on
other projects or whatever
but that's the longest of anything i've
done
uh five years why did it take so long
maybe that's not a long time no um i
think it took
a while and it was written in sort of
fits and starts because it was one of
the first
projects i started once i
started seriously writing so i didn't
know
yet not necessarily not that i didn't
know what i was doing because at times i
still don't feel like i know what i'm
doing when i write a screenplay but i
didn't know
a process that worked for me in terms of
creating something
so i just started writing i had a loose
outline and i just started writing
and i just kept hitting dead end after a
dead end
or i would figure something out that
didn't feel like a dead end but
i just it wasn't interesting to me so it
just wasn't
nothing was happening and so
i essentially had to start that project
almost
like i'd continue to start it over and
over
because i didn't have a process yet that
i felt comfortable with
and i didn't really know
what i was interested in writing about i
had a story idea but i didn't know why
that was a story idea that interested me
and moving forward it was always
important to me that when i was writing
something i always
understood before i really got into it
why i am interested in that story
and why i'm going to take that across
the finish line and that's been a really
useful tool
to help me with other story ideas that
i've had
that i think would be great movies i
think they're so cool
but i'm maybe not the one to write that
so
i shouldn't go after that yet but
there's still something that might
interest me so
i'll keep it in there and at some point
i go oh
i'm that's what i'm interested in that's
the theme
that comes out of that story that
resonates with me
and now i'm ready to start digging into
that it sounds like that story has a lot
of meaning for you
the initial idea um
it no now it does it it didn't at first
because i didn't have anything
but once i discovered that then i was
able to finish it and take it across the
finish line
and understand what i was
interested in writing about
okay do you think you'll have it made at
some point or
is it something where it's almost you
know certain stories people are like
like you said this isn't the story for
me to make but
it's a great idea um i think at this
point it's
a story that i'd love to see made but in
terms of where i am in my career right
now
it's a very big project
this was at a time when i was writing
before considerations
of my career what is the best
story that i can write and get into
the hands of producers i know and have
relationships with so this
project just isn't a good fit for the
people i know right now
and so it's still just kind of sitting
dormant and it's it's been out to a few
people to read for
feedback and thoughts um but nothing has
really
happened with it yet
you